it is the Pinnacle of a political career
PM's power is sometimes briefly at its
peak we ran for office as new labor we
will govern as new labor I came into
politics because I love this country
we're going to fulfill the repeated
Promises of parliament to the people but
the challenges for whoever succeeds
Boris Johnson are unprecedented we talk
about political honeymoons but this is
an economic nightmare you are at the
center of the storm Cade full remembers
the buzz and pressure of entering number
10. she was David Cameron's gatekeeper
for 11 years you might be woken in the
night to make a decision on National
Security you've got people coming in all
the time saying you know here's a folder
you need to look at this right now and
make a decision among the most sensitive
tasks on day one handwriting letters to
the UK's submarine commanders in case of
nuclear attack it brings home the fact
that you have such huge responsibilities
and some of that could be a decision
about life different death
Gavin barwell was Chief of Staff to
Theresa May and argues the new PM's
predecessor may also Loom large I think
Boris is going to be difficult for
whoever wins if it begins to go badly
for the new prime minister there's going
to be a sort of chorus of bring back
Boris I suspect he's going to go back to
writing a newspaper column and I can
tell you from my own experience when I
was chief of staff that those columns
are always newsworthy
the next PM may want to focus on foreign
policy like the war in Ukraine but the
domestic impact of that conflict will be
their first priority people are
absolutely scared and very worried about
what the next few months will bring
things are difficult now
and money that people have now they're
using just to try and make ends meet we
should be honest about the scale of the
cost to the government of intervening in
a bold and radical way and in a way that
is needed yes they've spent tens of
billions already but the cost could get
up to 100 billion
the next prime minister will enter this
street and that door with inflation
Rising GDP falling the cost of living
Christ is growing they'll inherit a
divided party with no mandate from
voters Liz truss saw Rishi sunak will
then need to survive the most
politically challenging of winters
before pivoting to an election pitch
if they lose that they will leave
Downing Street as the shortest serving
PM for almost 60 years it is an
unenviable intrain Joe Pike Sky News
Westminster